foreign
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're going
to be doing a big breakdown on
Transformers rise of the beasts the
brand new trailer for the movie dropped
last week and I thought I'd do a big
video covering that the new characters
cast release date and everything you
need to know about the movie the film is
due to release on the 9th of June in the
US it was originally meant to drop on
the 24th but they bumped it up a bit to
the one week next year where I'm on
holiday fingers crossed for an early
screening but this will be introducing a
lot of major characters into the
franchise starring Anthony Ramos and
Dominique Fishback will watch as the
stars of Beast Wars abroad into the
franchise in order to integrate them all
together the timeline for the movie
franchise is messier than a Targaryen
family tree but this will be a
continuation of the continuity that was
first starred out in bumblebee that was
a prequel to The Original Transformers
franchise and the movie starred hailee
Steinfeld who sadly won't be returning
for this it will be continuing on from
that though in order to start a new
Trilogy with this movie that was set in
the 80s and this film will be picking up
in 1994 setting in after that but before
the original franchise films with Shia
LaBeouf I remember covering the Netflix
Trilogy and I had to constantly keep
explaining how Stuff had changed from
certain timelines to the other which is
probably going to be something that we
have to do here too Transformers is
almost 40 years old at this point and
it's covered so many different movies
shows games and so on that there was
always going to be clashes in the
continuity now in this movie we'll see
the maximals and terracons along with
the Autobots the maximals are the
descendants of the Autobots and
depending on what continuity you read
there's time travel involved with them
going back to the past lots of timey why
me wibbly wobbly stuff but the main
villains of the movie will be the
terracons who are hunting down the
autobots and also the maximals Optimus
primal could have come back from the
feature in order to warn him and this
may lead to them going further into the
past which we'll talk about more later
on now Peter Dinklage will be playing
Scourge who is the terracons group
leader he can transform into a black
Kenwood slogging truck and he will be
joined by several others this includes
night bird who changes into a Nissan
Skyline and also battle trap who's going
to be turning into a General Motors
c4500 I think that I think that's how
you say now the form will be voiced by
Michaela J Rodriguez with David sobolov
playing the ladder scourges ties with
Unicron which is a planet-sized machine
that's traveled through the universe and
reality itself now I have a feeling that
they'll end up teasing towards Unicron
much like how they tease towards Thanos
in the MCU in the last night it was
revealed that Unicron was actually the
Earth itself and potentially Scourge
could be trying to find a way to
weaponize this now the trailer actually
gives a lot away and from the off it's
filled with the idea that we'll be
seeing a clash between jungles and more
modern industrialization we start off
with a jungle shell of Peru before
cutting to New York the text over the
top talks about how our world is
transformed them too I think they're
clearly showing they've got lots of
Aesthetics going on now Anthony Ramos
will be playing Noah and by the looks of
it he's in deep with the Autobots due to
him having a Porsche that's actually
Mirage how he comes to get this we don't
know as he seems to get in the car and
then be surprised at what it can do he's
chased by the police so potentially he
was trying to steal it and it was the
one that ended up taking him for a
joyride and there's lots of other
explanations for this and he might have
just seen the cost sitting there with
its door waving over to him like come on
Noah come get a red balloon now Mirage
will be played by Mr Steely old girl AKA
Pete Davidson the guy is taking some
time away from waking up covered in
women and he'll be playing the car who
seems like he's good friends with Noah
he's taken him too and who knows what
the guy's Gonna Get Next you can't keep
getting away with it he's comfortable
enough to transform around him and he
also helps him invade the police by
creating duplicate cars this is a mirage
and the characters tapping into his
holographic abilities in order to pull
off this Escape Mirage has actually
appeared in the films before as he
briefly popped up as a red Ferrari back
in Dark of the Moon but I don't know if
we talk about that anymore now the
trailer gives up the goods right up top
with us having Optimus Prime meeting
Optimus primal these are two major
characters from separate timelines that
rarely unite due to how many issues with
the continuity that it would end up
causing it's awesome seeing them here
working together though and I love how
suspicious primers from the off I don't
know how they're gonna work the timeline
but my assumption is that they'll go
with the more classically accepted one
and have the maximals being factions
that have taken over the Autobots their
War still continued and they were
launched back into the past along with
the Predacons they sent them back
millions and millions of years ago and
they'll likely wedded it out until the
time is right or this Theory time is
completely wrong the way that Optimus
Prime jumps down makes me think that no
Elena are working with the Autobots due
to Mirage and that is now protecting
them he's been looking over there and he
jumps down after believing that Primal
is a threat
[Music]
I'm not the one to fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming now if you
look closely at primal's chest you'll
notice the maximal emblem this is shown
at the end of the trailer in the logo as
well and it's really cool seeing it here
he also has fur around the shoulder pads
indicating that this is something
they're adding to the design of the
maximals Prime is ready to smash him
like he's the like button but instead he
thinks he should wait and hear him out
and why he should subscribe a giant
monkey and I love seeing them both on
screen together at the same time going
as my bloody wallpaper that now Prime is
voiced by Unicron Pearlman and he's
actually played the character before
back in 2018 he voiced Primal and
Transformers power of the primes a
Prime's design has changed slightly and
he looks slightly more removed from a
truck than he has been in the past his
chest especially has a Change-Up to it
there's more silver to him and I also
think his face looks kinda simplified
compared to what we've had in the past
over the top of this we hear notorious
b.i.g's juicy and the rapper came from
Brooklyn which is coupled nicely with
the shot of the Brooklyn Bridge the
lights flicker on and off and this is
going on his prime list talking about a
big incoming threat therefore I think
this is likely power being pulled from
the planet by the terracons who may want
to use it to create Energon it however
might link back to Unicron but again big
theater
on that one I'll stop I'd stop doing
that now now bribe can be seen on the
bridge watching this happen first hand
and it's somewhat Echoes the ending of
Bumblebee with him riding out now
speaking of Bumblebee we see him in the
next shot transforming currently there's
no voice actor attached to him and
because of the rest of the cast list
being out I'm guessing that is just
gonna have him talking through his radio
this will mess up the continuity as with
Sam he of course had to do that and in
bumblebee lost his voice so yeah at
least they're keeping that streamlined
they're going with the silent but
violent route now bumblebee is Prime's
right hand Tran and with this following
unpromised solo film we might get some
of the backstory filled in on what's
happened between that and that he was
sent to Earth to establish a base which
is possibly something that we could
visit in the film from here we get the
car chase and the policeman saying
to which Noah replies no it's a cardigan
but thanks for noticing wait wait wrong
clip now we get a shot of Bumblebee are
riding alongside Cheeto who is a cheetah
you got it mate this helps to
demonstrate his size and speed and we
can see him running alongside an
off-road bumblebee he is still a Camaro
however he has been altered slightly to
deal with the terrain great should have
these Sidekicks riding alongside each
other and they're pretty much the right
hand partners of their respective primes
chidor and Beast Wars could pass as the
animal itself however much like Primal
the luck has been changed for the movie
rather than being able to appear like an
earth animal they're clearly creatures
that have taken the design rather than
becoming animals themselves they have
this size and strength that you'd expect
from the maximals but they aren't hiding
out
from this point we get introduced to air
Azor this giant Bird's gonna be voiced
by Michelle yo who's coming off the back
of the seminal everything everywhere all
at once eraser ax very much as the eyes
in the sky for the maximals and she can
provide strategic Insight whilst also
being a deadly photo go against designed
primarily for Recon she is potentially
scouting the area and providing air
support for the maximals you see her
blasting a bridge almost like a dragon
demonstrating just how devastating she
can be now if you look closely at this
shot you can also see a figure running
along the path they're very small and
difficult to make out with YouTube's
compression not really helping that much
either I did try and zoom in to see who
that was but there's not enough yet
where I could say for definite exactly
who it is this could be the maximals and
Autobots getting their wires crossed pun
not intended and going against each
other when they should be allies this
part of the movie definitely seems like
it's gonna be a big action scene as we
see a boulder falling along with several
machines the one at the back looks like
Optimus and there's also a car in the
distance you can see following as well
from here we see battle trap who's
firing a missile this seems to be coming
out of the exhaust on top of the hood of
the car without being a really cool way
to transform something we've seen time
and time again into a deadly weapon now
this is being fired at RC who he ends up
missing she's hanging out of another
Transformer which is called wheel Jack
in the original film franchise wheel
Jack's look was based on Albert Einstein
and the genius inventor helped to create
several devices that have aided the
humans in Autobots a man a man died in
Dark Side of the Moon
now he's going to be voiced by Christo
Fernandez with Liza koshy he'll be
playing RC such a good shot seeing her
hanging off the side with the doors open
and her dodging that missile in slow
motion
there's a lot of slow motion the
episodes were running up to eight
minutes under
the only way to stretch them out was
with slow motion
and we tried to keep the slow motion
away from the dialogue as much as
possible
but anything without dialogue was
considered for slow motion now Aussie is
roller skating alongside wheel Jack
firing her guns and looking like a G1
wearing that combat visor RC first
showed up in the films during Revenge of
the Fallen and she too appeared in
bumblebee during the Cybertron scene you
already know how she dies in the
franchise so it won't be here but it is
nice seeing her show up now after a
quick cut of Primal we see what looks
like it could be the death of Bumblebee
however I have a theory time
in Addiction in time
and that is that this isn't the case
here on the ground we can catch Optimus
Prime looking defeated with Scourge
walking towards him this is our first
look at the villain in the teaser and
they introduce him in a big bad way
bumblebee jumps at him but the villain
then turns around and stabs him right
through the chest it's a big way to
bring the character in and it's also
nice that they aren't just going with
the usual the usual Megatron villanoc
this new quote-unquote reboot that was
start off with bumblebee has done well
steering clear of that villain that
we've seen countless times I like that
they've put focus on Scourge rather than
Megatron again I know I know he's
trapped over look this [ __ ] my head's
longer with the continuity but yeah it
just anything to avoid using him over
and over again now how does Bumblebee
get out of this that was the original
Point well I don't think that that's
actually him Mirage has already shown
that they can do duplicates and well
mirages and thus I think this is a trick
at the last second in order to distract
Scourge in one of the wide shots we see
see that there are lots of blue lights
around them and though this could be
electricity it also resembles the
holographic images that Mirage puts out
I don't know if the images hold up to
the point where they can be stabbed but
that's just what I thought when watching
over this moment Optimus is awesome what
appears to be a hexagon and shout out to
the Raging Nation for pointing out that
this could be related to Cybertron and
Tech to keep him in place we get another
shot where Scourge is holding Bumblebee
and can see that his face has changed up
to be more in line with the all my luck
that he takes on from here we cut to a
shot of humans and any Autobots we can
see wheel Jack at the front in his robot
form and this is the group traveling to
Peru this links back to the jungles we
talked about earlier and we can see that
there's a festival going on there there
were some clips taken by locals that
were posted on YouTube and it showed
Optimus Prime and Co out at the location
orionox is someone we haven't touched
upon in the video so far but the
following shot establishes that they're
gonna be in the movie according to
collider they'll also be voiced by David
sabalov and this giant rhinoceros is one
of the most powerful maximals there is
was one of my favorite toys as a kid and
he was basically your Hulk Powerhouse
figure that packed both abroad and
brains it looks like he can fire out of
his mouth and a nice little detail is
that the character's tongue can be seen
as well I think he's just roaring here
but this helps to set up the ramping up
of the trailer it says some machines
Crash Landing into the Hudson and we can
see three coming down this is obviously
the terracons who are the only team in
the film that have three members this
possibly happens just before the
Brooklyn Bridge scene and potentially
they land here and start to suck the
power out which is why the lights on the
bridge flash on and off this would make
Optimus aware of them as he's riding
along the top of it and then they could
head to Peru to investigate what's going
on now them coming crashing down is
coupled with Optimus transforming and
getting his armor together which makes
for such a good shot to tease the
incoming threat his face plate slides on
and I'm glad they've included this as
sometimes it seems like they're just
going leave it off now at this point we
get what is the money shot of the
trailer with a big battle playing out
originally I thought that this might
have been in the past but there are some
indicators that it's happening towards
the end of the movie or at least later
on after the two good sides have met we
have battle trap running forward and to
the left hand side a purple Transformer
flies by if we look at the concept of
the film this is gonna be night bird and
as we mentioned at the start of the
video they are going to be featuring in
the movie Cheeto runs forward in Beast
form before transforming as he jumps
over a rock lastly we see Optimus primal
change and if you look to the right you
can see Optimus Prime's red arm he also
has his blade out and this is clearly
cementing that this happens after
they've met unless they're doing an MCU
and lying to us in the trailers now
because of the landscape this might be
in the past with them potentially
traveling back there in order to stop
the terracons it's possible that the
maximals could even be stuck in some
sort of time Loop where they meet the
Autobots travel back to stop the
terracons to get stuck there and then
have to wait it out until a present to
do the whole thing over again it was
probably a pretty stupid Theory but you
know we're just going off a trailer here
mate calm down and we can see a ship
behind them that looks like it's Crash
landed and this could be where the
terracons came from after they hit the
planet they might be going back to stop
them which could bring everything full
circle that's me really clutching at
straws and you think you think you get a
bit sick of it after a while if it was
just one big loop as mentioned up top
though timelines are a mess in the
Transformers verse so they may travel
back and the rest of the trilogy could
be about them being stuck in the past
anyway next to Primal we can also see
rhinox and potentially Cheeto beside him
we end with Primal leaping towards
battle trap and the trailer closes out
with a nice little joke before we see
Noah and Mirage showing up they look all
casual like look look how casual this is
got the whole walking away from
explosion feel to to it and that closes
out the trailer interesting detail is
that we can see dismantled plane wings
to the side possibly teasing at a plane
based Transformer showing up in this
scene anyway that's all we could unpack
from the teaser and tidbits that we have
on the movie I know it's been a long
time coming but Thursday was manic with
all the trailers and then I was in
hospital on Friday and had to recover
over the weekend Monday was Rick and
Morty and then I've been putting this
together over the last couple of days so
I hope you guys don't mind the wait I'm
excited for the movie and this teaser
has a lot going on with it as well as
some really interesting characters
coming to the Forefront such a good way
to get me hyped for 2023 and I think the
movie is going to be something special
as I love the new timeline well the same
timeline but the the prequels well the
Bumblebee was actually my favorite
Transformers film little in case you
wanted to know that and carrying on from
that has me hyped even if we don't have
Haley Seinfeld back either way that's
everything we know so far and I hope you
enjoy the video we are in competition
right now and giving away three copies
of House of the Dragon season 1 on the
15th of December and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the trailer you
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers good smiles to watch then make
sure you check out our Brighton of the
Guardians trailer which will be linked
on the screen right now we all wear
everything in it all the Easter eggs the
new characters whatever you want to know
it's in that so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for singing through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace